vacation rentals are giving a
lot to talk about in these times that
such health to cristian casseres I
tell you that in some parts of the valley
short-term rentals are not
allowed this could change very
soon state legislators approved
a bill which  requires
park county to regulate this type of
short term rental by the first of
July they are now waiting to
see the results of an
online survey to get the opinions of
all residents and there is no more
mandatory vaccination for students
university students the legislative commission
voted Tuesday night against
this measure which had originally
been approved during the summer those
students without vaccination could not
enroll in class but now they can
however it is another scenario for
employees since they do need the
vaccine  against cob and legislators
also put a stop to the
mandatory vaccine for employees  federal states
that are in close contact with the
vulnerable population
and see these images i tell you that the
line rents will celebrate its 9 years of
service to the public with an event this
weekend under the name center class
starting on wednesday you can visit
the place  to learn more about the
treasure hunt share the story
with abbas and the giraffe and see the lions
receive special gifts the hours are
from 11 in the morning until 3 in the
afternoon and everything ends on Sunday and we
close with the weather forecast
As we can see, we will have a
partially cloudy sky with temperatures
reaching 59 degrees. On Thursday
the winds will return and by Friday
we expect rain here in the valley. I am
Cristian Cásseres with his brief
news report on News Now in Spanish,
happy holidays and a good day
[Music]